[موسيقى]
رمضان يعني كنافه طبق الكنافه على سفره
رمضان تقليد تورثنا في مصر ابا عن جد
وخاصه الكنافه التقليديه اللي بتتعمل
بالعسل والمكسرات والقشطه الكنافه اللي
بتعملها الامهات والجدات في البيوت
مكسرات وقشطه وبعدين مش موضوع الشربات ده
ادم خلاص ولا ايه اصلا دلوقتي ما بقاش
اسمها الكنافه يعني دلوقتي بقى في
المتدلعه في الهيصه في الليصه كلها اطباق
بتجمع ما بين حلويات رمضان المتنوعه يعني
الكنافه مع بلح الشام بالشوكولا او
المانجا او التريليتشي او حتى اللوتس
هي واضح ان الكنافه حكايتها اتغيرت في مصر
او ضوء المصريين هو اللي اتغير
[موسيقى]
كل سنه الحمد لله بنعمل نفس الموضوع ده
يعني
كنافه المانجا طبعا دي مشهوره قوي بقى
حاليا من قبل كده وحاليا
وكنافه
كنافه نوتيلا
نعمل مثلا
اورانجولات مانجا
يعني حوالي اربعه اطعمه ولكن السياحات
والتقاليع دي مرفوضه تماما عند كتير من
المصريين الكنافه بالنسبه لهم يعني كنافه
التقليديه مش عايزين عليها اي اضافات تغير
طعمها بالع انا شايفه ان التقاليع دي عملت
من الكنافه التقليديه طبق معاصر يواكب نمط
الحياه اللي اصبح كمان خليط بين الاحداث
الغير تقليديه
[موسيقى]
الاسماء دي ولا ولا تعمل حاجه دي المفروض
انا من قبل ما بسمعها بحيث مجرد للجزم
تيجي في الاخر
مجرد دعايه للبيع بس والله بحب البتاعه
البيت يعني على طول وكده يعني بحبها بس
يعني بحب اجرب برضه اشوف برضه الايه
الحاجات الجديده وكده نجرب يعني زي ناس
بتجرب يعني الحاجات اللي انا بتطلع جديده
اشطوطه وبشطوطه والحاجات ديت طبعا بتشد
البني ادم طبعا هي بيلعبوا على الحته دي
بيلعبوا على الحته بتاعه الاسماء بجرب
بجرب عجبتني ماشي ما عجبتنيش واخد بالك بص
بقى الحاجات القديمه بتاعتي ارجع لها ثاني
كنافه نوتيلا محترمه الملفوف كويس بس في
الاول وفي الاخر المنتجه كنافه
[موسيقى]
دي متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات